Why don't you want kids excuse me? I?
I saw, how you reacted earlier I?
I know what it's like when you're just starting out and you think you have all the time in the world and
You know you're not going to be so young forever
Have kids
Then you'll be creating something together
This is all just
setting
um you do want
mother
What brings you to us? Well? They told me I could find a room here. He thought we were to bed him breakfast
He's a stranger. We're just gonna when I'm sleeping our house
Hello, can I help you waiting? Did you know he had a wife?
He didn't just stumble on us he has pictures of you in his luggage. What were you doing in there?
God help you. I'm trying to do breathe into this hand
You give and you give and you give? It's just never enough